shocking video shows a suspect attempt
to drive off all while dragging a police
officer from the moving vehicle okay
officials with the Greeley Colorado
Police Department say it happened on
December 2nd with suspect 34 year old
Donald Turley at the
wheelchair
hey earlier that day officers tried to
stop a stolen vehicle it got away but a
GPS tracking Dart found its location
officers tracked the vehicle to a
property in Weld County where they found
Turley moving a different stolen vehicle
when officers attempted to arrest Turley
he hit the gas during the escape attempt
he took an officer with him
after that officers pulled out their
weapons and Turley stopped he was then
taken into custody do not even try to
run lay down lay down Shirley was
arrested and booked on multiple
outstanding warrants and several other
charges including two counts of
second-degree assault on a peace officer
aggravated motor vehicle theft reckless
endangerment and resisting arrest for
the latest developments in this story
and all things True Crime stay with long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie